SENATOR GRAHAM ONE OF TRUMP'S
BIGST CRITICS AND NOW MAY BE THE
WHISPERER.
HE'S BECOME ABOUT UNEXPECTED
ALLY ON ALL ACCOUNTS.
WHAT DOES HE THINK ABOUT TRUMP'S
FIRST YEAR, ROBERT MUELLER
INVESTIGATION AND WHY JANUARY
MIGHT BE BIG FOR CONGRESS.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
>> IT'S A GOOD LEAD IN.
THANKS VERY MUCH.
>> IT'S FASCINATING THE WAY YOU
WENT AT IT AND NOW YOU HAVE
ABOUT UP FRONT RESPECT FOR EACH
OTHER.
WHY DO YOU BELIEVE SOMETHING
WILL GET DONE WITH IMMIGRATION?
WHAT CAN YOU TELL THE PEOPLE
HEADING INTO THE NEW YEAR?
ACT KIDS TO HAVE A GOOD LIFE.
THEY HAVE NOWHERE TO GO.
THEY HAVE BEEN HERE SINCE THEY
WERE SMALL KIDS.
80% OF THE PEOPLE WANT TO SEE
THE BORDER SECURED.
BORDER SECURITY WITH A WALL
MAKES SENSE.
MOST AMERICANS WANT TO GET AWAY
FROM CHAIN MIGRATION.
THERE IS A DEAL TO BE HAD.
THE ONLY REASON WE WON'T GET A
DEAL IS THAT PEOPLE ARE STUBBORN
AND CAN'T GET TO YES.
>> SENATOR SCHUMER SAID DACA IS
SECURITY, AND WE ARE NOT LINKING
YOU THINK THAT IS NOT REALITY?
THE IDEA THAT WE HAVE THE DREAM
ACT, YOU WANT TO ADDRESS CHAIN
MIGRATION, BORDER SECURITY DONE
BE LINKED?
YOU WORK IT OUT IN A BI-PARTISAN
WAY BEHIND THE SCENES, AND YOU
PUT IT TO HIM.
THE MAJORITY OF REPUBLICS DON'T
GO FOR IT.
>> I THINK IT WOULD BE HARD TO
GO HOME AND SAY YOU VOTED
AGAINST A SECURED BORDER WITH A
WALL COMPONENT.
HE WILL GET A WALL AND BORDER
SECURITY BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT HE
RAN ON.
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
REPUBLICS LIKE MYSELF FOR A
DECADE NOW TRYING TO FIX THE
DREAM ACT.
>> HERE'S WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO DO.
I WOULD LIKE THE PRESIDENT TO
ADDRESS THE STATE OF THE UNION
AND SAY I INCREASED DEFENSE
SPENDING.
OUR MILITARY SUFFERED TOO LONG.
WE HAVE A BORDER SECURED.
THE DREAM ACT KIDS HAVE A BETTER
LIFE.
WE ARE MOVING FROM A LOTTERY
SYSTEM TO A MERIT BASED
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
>> ONLY IF DICK DURBIN WOULD SAY
THAT.
IF HE'S NOT NODDING SOMEWHERE IN
ILLINOIS, WE ARE NOT GOING TO
GET ANYWHERE.
SENATOR, I WANT TO MOVE TO ONE
OF PRESIDENT TRUMP'S 101 TWEETS
IN THE LAST FEW DAYS.
IN THE INTERVIEW OVER THE LAST
FEW DAYS, AT HIS GRILL IN
HONEST JOB.
HE'S CONFIDENT HE WILL DO A GOOD
JOB ON THE INVESTIGATION.
DO YOU BELIEVE HE'S PURSUING
>> HE'S THE RIGHT GUY TO HAVE
HE'S NOT LOOKING AT THE DOSSIER.
THAT'S NOT PART OF HIS CHARTER.
I SPENT TIME IN THE LAST COUPLE
OF DAYS AFTER FIGHTING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO GET THE
BACKGROUND OF THE DOSSIER.
I CAN TELL YOUR VIEWERS I'M
DISTURBED BY THE DOSSIER.
>> I HAVE BEEN A LAWYER MOST OF
MY LIFE, A PROSECUTOR AND
DEFENSE ATTORNEY.
EVERY PROSECUTOR HAS THE DUTY TO
DISCLOSE THINGS RELY VEPT TO A R
DISCLOSE THINGS RELY VEPT TO A O
DISCLOSE THINGS RELY VEPT TO A A
REQUEST.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OWES
IT TO THE COURT TO BE UP AND UP
INVOLVED, WHAT THEIR MOTIVATES
MIGHT BE.
I CAN SAY THIS, AFTER LOOKING AT
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
I'M CONCERNED, AND THIS CANNOT
BE THE NEW NORMAL.
NAME THE COMPANY IN SOUTH
CAROLINA RESPONDING TO THE TAX
REFORM AND HOW.
>> PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANY, 5%
WAGE INCREASE TO ALL OF THEIR
EMPLOYEES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S TAX CUT IS
GOING TO HELP WORKING PEOPLE.